what is worse in signal instances
writers musicians artists and academics
sided more or less overtly or by
indifference with the agencies of the
inhuman Goethe's garden is a few
thousand yards from Buchenwald
Heidegger lectured on her Dylan
software regarded occupied Paris I quote
as a perfect for literary and
philosophical action end of quote
in short when we invoke the ideals and
practices of the humanities there is no
assurance you touched on this in your
most generous introduction there's no
assurance that they humanize my sense of
the question simply to immense me I use
the great phrase of the American poet
Wallace Stevens supreme fictions supreme
fictions
may may enable us to forget the cry in
the street I come from a seminar in the
afternoon having taught let's say the
certain force act of Lear I am
completely completely enveloped in the
tortures of Cordelia and the cry of Leah
never never never never never
and somebody's screaming in the street
helped me and I don't hear it in some
mysterious sense I don't hear this
haunts me a second major factor may
relate to the democratization of higher
education to the accelerating extension
of University entry to virtually every
order in society yes
human potentialities are indeed
widespread yes
they are far too often suffocated by
economic injustice and discrimination
ladies and gentlemen the faculties of
the human mind its potentialities are
not are not infinitely elastic sorry
talent let alone genius in the arts is
enigmatic ly rare and unpredictable so
it is in the gymnastics of the brain the
number women of men and of men of men
and of women qualified to respond to a
chorus in Aeschylus
to categorical proof in comment to it we
know Duino elegies Rilke may be larger
than hierarchical reactionary ideologies
assume it is not however limitlessly
large the sciences have no hypocrisy
about this we do we humanists lie to
ourselves continually the sciences say
sorry you can't do an equation of the
fifth degree sorry goodbye become a
banker you don't survive a first-rate
science course of the first year if you
don't know how to do the damn things
they don't block they can't Bluff
they're not going to lose that time with
bluffing the science is rapidly weed out
the inept those tomb elliptical
functions or string theory are simply
inaccessible
there is no egalitarian contract no
Democratic agreement with transfinite
numbers believe me today the humanities
flinch from any rigour in recruitment
from any acknowledgment that the
enrollments in many spheres of social
and literary studies are bloated and
vulgarized
to a destructive measure it has become
almost impossible
to get rid of students totally
unqualified to take your class has
become almost impossible administrative
leap oolitic li ideologically our
science colleagues have no such problems
they know what they're doing and they
say sorry this is becoming true and true
as the science has become more and more
complex li mathematical there may in the
final analysis be a structural element
in our crisis we noted the co logical
origins of our Western universities and
that the emancipation from theology has
left a kind of emptiness a disabling
void
Cardinal moves in academic teacher and
research were grounded in theological
assumptions of authority outdoor eat us
that beautiful world of textual
precedent and reference of tradition
inevitably the secular disciplines
transferred developed techniques of
understanding communication and former
presentment inherited from what are
understandably still schooled schools of
divinity but the substantive
legitimation the underwriting that's a
very powerful word to under write
something to reinsure
the underwriting on which these
axiomatic reflexes were founded on now
like reproachful ghosts they can no
longer provide reinsurance in the
beginning was the word the logos from it
evolved human istic literacy when that
word is no longer audible the
ontological foundations of philosophic
literary and historical studies abroad